BRETT BAVAR: All right,
welcome everybody.
Today's talk is "Building
Real-time Web Apps with App
Engine and the Feed API".
My name is Brett Bavar, and I'm
a software engineer on the
Google Ajax API's team.
MOISHE LETTVIN: And, I'm Moishe
Lettvin, and I'm a software
engineer on the developer
platforms team.
BRETT BAVAR: If you want to
view live notes or participate
in the wave for this session,
you can go to this URL.
I'm going to leave it up for a
second and read it off to you,
because it's kind of crazy.
[? Bit ?]
[? lee ?]
slash DC6 capital-Q
X capital-D.
Or,
if you've been doing waves, you
should be able to look through
the official Google
IO wave list.
You should find our session
amongst theirs with the wave
button I believe on the
official Google IO web site
for the information
on this session.
You should be able to find the
wave button is there as well.
All right, so before we get
started, I wanted to give you a
little bit of context about
what we're talking about when
we say the real time web.
So, I'm
sure all of you are familiar
with this site right
here, Google.com.
For a long time, Google.com
has made search results
available to us.
Say I wanted to search for
what people are saying
about Google IO.
You can see here, I get
some very good results.
But, they don't change.
When I'm viewing the page,
they just stay the same.
I'd have to refresh if I
wanted to get new content.
It's probably not even going to
change that frequently anyway.
The one thing I can do now, as
you may know, -- there is a
new version of this called
Google Real-time Search.
I can see new things
that are coming in.
You can see right here 24
seconds ago, something was said
on Twitter about Google IO and
things are continuing
to come in.
This is one example of
the real time web.
Things are coming in
constantly, content that
users are interested in.
And we want to make it
available to them as easy and
fast as possible without
having to refresh the page.
This is one example of
the real-time web.
And lots of people are trying
to add this to their web
apps and their web sites.
But, it's not as easy to
do as you might think.
So, we want to talk to you
about some new ways that you
can add this kind of real-time
functionality to your web page.
We're here to announce
and explain a couple
new tools for this.
First, the app engine channel
API which Moishe has built, and
will introduce you to that.
It allows you to push things
in real time in App Engine.
And, second, I will talk to you
about Feed API Version 2 with
the new functionality for
push updates on feeds.
At this point I'll pass it
over to Moishe to explain
the App Engine Channel API.
MOISHE LETTVIN: Cool,
thanks, Brett.
I have a brief agenda of what
I'm going to cover here.
As a way of introducing this
API, I want to talk about how
things are now, and a problem
that you may have run
into with the way things
are now at App Engine.
Then, I'll describe what
the Channel API does
to solve that problem.
I'll talk about how to use it.
I'll show some code snippets,
and how it works under
the covers briefly, some
implementation details.
So, to get started, have
you all used App Engine?
Do we have App Engine
developers in the room?
Sweet!
So, you know the
basic flow, right?
App Engine is basically, you
write your app as a bunch
of request handlers.
So typical case, a user types
your apps address into the
browser, they navigate to
your site, and you get
a request in your app.
Your app delivers a response
down to the browser.
The browser renders your
client page and then
that's kind of it.
Your browser now has the bundle
of Javascript and HTML and
whatever data you
delivered to it.
And the user can
interact with that.
The problem is, let's say you
are writing a chess game, just
a simple two-player chess game,
and the other player
makes a move.
Some event happens to your app.
Your app's state in
the clolud changes.
How do you tell the
client that happen?
Anybody?
How do you tell the other
person in this chess game that
somebody moved their rook
up, or moved a pawn, or
captured their queen?
You poll.
Exactly.
And, this is a
pretty common case.
There's this is really neat app
that someone wrote called
SeeMyCode.com I don't know how
many of you guys do phone
interviews, but a really common
challenge with phone interviews
is you want to talk to somebody
over the phone and see if they
actually write code before you
bring them on site to see
if they can write
code even better.
But, it's super-hard to
dictate code over the phone.
When I did my phone screen for
Google, they asked me this
complicated thing and I had a
note pad with like ten pages
of code, and I was trying
to dictate this over my
interviewer, and it sucked.
So this guy wrote this
SeeMyCode.com web site,
which is awesome.
You go there and you basically
see as the other person
types what they typed in.
But he has to use
polling to do that.
So thats an example of
something where you end up
falling back to polling.
If you want to write a group
chat on top of your app,
you'd need to do polling.
Basically, any time that
there's a person who you're
interacting with on the other
side where there's basically
there's no set time limit
where something happens.
You don't have a good
way to be notified when
something's changed.
So you can use polling.
As you're probably aware if
you've ever written anything
with polling, polling sucks.
And why does it suck?
Here's typical flow; you set a
set interval call in your
Javascript to ask your app up
on the server, did
something happen?
Nope.
Did something happen?
Something happen?
Nope.
Eventually something may
happen, but you're putting a
lot of load on your service
for nothing, really.
For something that may
or may not happen.
So, the other thing that stinks
-- I actually just had to write
a polling implementation for
the development app server for
the channel API, so that we can
simulate this on your own
machine without comment.
So, you end having all these
cues of messages that are
waiting to be delivered to
your app and then you've got
delivery happening on the
Javascript and the client side.
Its a big pain in the butt, and
everybody ends up writting that
same basic code over
and over again.
It should a solved problem.
And, the other thing that about
polling, if you want any sort
of reasonable latency you're
going drive your CPU and
codings up or if you want to
pay any reasonable amount for
CPU and quota usage, your
latency is going to go down to
something that might be
unacceptable depending
on your app.
And what you don't see on this
graph, because it's not 3D, is,
of course, this whole curve
gets pushed out a lot as you
get more and more users.
So, I have a solution for you.
Same basic flow.
The browser makes request
to your app engine app.
Your app engine app delivers a
bundle of Javascript, HTML
and data, but, bonus, your
Javascript app creates a
long-standing comet connection
up to the app engine service.
It's not actually
connected to your app.
It's connected to a Google
server that's able to
push data down to it.
So, now, when something happens
in your app, your app can
notify your client that
there's something new there.
The API itself is much easier
than ginning up your own
polling API where you've got to
deal with messages and so on.
And, also it lets you just
step off this curve of
latency to CPU you use.
I don't have exact numbers for
this yet, the PM's are still
figuring that out, but
it is cheaper, and
significantly faster.
So I'd like to show a demo
of this, and you guys are
welcome to join me in this.
I'll tell you the
URL.
So if you go to
IOTriviaQuiz.AppsBot.com
Now, we'll set up the game.
We've got some questions.
You guys can shout out answers
to these and I'll answer these.
The author of a webcomic
of Romance, Sarcasm,
Math and Language?
All right, Randall Munroe.
And you see other
people are joining in.
You can see there's an
activities stream at the bottom
that's being updated as people
answer questions and there's no
polling involving here.
At least no polling that
you as a user of the API
have to worry about.
And, we can actually look at
the Chrome resources here, you
can see that there's binds.
This is the comet connection
that's happening, and there's
posts that I'm making up to the
server when I make a response.
But there's no-- if this was a
polling app, you'd actually see
every second or every ten
seconds or whatever, another
request going up and you
don't see that here.
So, that's that.
Now one thing to note with
this app, we are sharding.
There's 10 users per games,
so if you don't see your
name up here, that's why.
You're in a game with
another set of nine users.
So, let me tell you to
actually build that.
So, you can see there in upper
right, there's little key and
basically I'll highlight
whether I'm talking about
server code or client code
as I talk through this.
It should be pretty obvious
because its Python on the
server side and Javascript
on the client's side.
So, to start with when you get
a request in your app, you'll
have a get-handler for your
index page or whatever and
there's basically two
calls you need to make.
The first is, you create a
channel, and you can see
that you specify a key to
identify that channel.
That's up to your application
to provide and it can
be whatever you want.
What I usually use is get
current users user ID.
Basically one client per user,
but you could use database
key or whatever you choose.
And you're given back an ID
which is a token that the
client uses to connect
to that channel.
So the next line you can see
here; we inject that token
into a template, write
that as the response.
Now on the client's side,
similarly, this is a template,
so we're getting that channel
ID that was injected
in previously.
We use that channel ID to
create a new channel.
Then we open a socket on that
channel, and set a call back
handler for when an event
happens on that channel.
So, very straightforward.
And that really is all
there is to the API.
There's a few other event
handlers and the like.
But in essence, you create a
channel, you passed the token
down to the client, you open
that channel on the client,
and you set callback handlers
for when things happen.
And, then, of course, now
you've got this channel
open on the client's side.
Something else happens.
You've got your other page;
you're make move or your answer
questions page or what have
you, and you send a message to
that channel with the key that
you used above to create it.
Not the ID that is handed back
but the key that you used,
and then a string message.
This is typically like a JSON
encoded object that you decode
in javascript or whatever.
But it's just a string.
Whatever you want to
put in there, you can.
And then, when you do that, the
callback handler is called
on the client's side.
And, in this case, we alert,
but you'd update your UI as
appropriate based on that.
Some quick details, the
Python implementation
again is just two methods.
Create a channel, send a
message to that channel.
Java implementation
is the same.
Some tactics differences.
You pass a channel message
object in for Java instead of
just two parameters, but its
effectively the same thing.
A couple more details on
the javascript side.
You include this is underscore
AH channel JS API.
Underscore AH is like the App
Engine kind of internal stuff,
so we have this JS API
depending on whether you are
running on the development apps
server or on production,
this will return
you a different bundle
of Javascript.
So we basically do a
redirect in production.
On the develop app server,
it's our clunky pulling
implementation, but it, at
least, lets you try it
out before pushing it.
And, this socket, you may
notice, instead of just opening
the channel, we open a
socket on the channel.
The reason for that is, we want
to maintain compatibility kind
of moving forward with
the web socket API.
So, the object you get back
from channel.open is a normal
Javascript object but it
mirrors this functionality.
It has all these methods on it.
It will set the ready state,
buffered amount, it doesn't
use, because its not relevant
here, but the idea is that in
the future if we can support
web sockets for this
channel API, we will.
It'll be a transparent
switch for people who
are using this API.
Couple more implication
details here.
Before, I' just had this big
generic block for App Engine.
The way this actually works is
that App Engine will actually
talk to the Google Talk XMPP
layer, so we're using -- I
don't know if you guys are
familiar with the XMPP API for
App Engine already -- We've
basically built this on top of
that, so we can use our
existing stack, this very
scalable stack to deliver XMPP
messages, for this stuff, so
basically it's routed through
the whole stack to get
messages down to your app.
And, on the the client side,
since we're connecting to talk
front-ends to get these
messages, rather than a server
on your domain we've created an
invisible i-frame that actually
handles the long pull, the
comet connection, up to a
Google server and then
communicate from that
i-frame using closure XPC.
I don't know if you guys are
familiar with this, but it's a
way to do communication between
frames on different domains
inside a browser, and it'll
basically use whatever the most
efficient method is for the
browser that's hosting it.
So the flow is, you get
a message down from
the top front.
It's been translated into an
XPC call out to your frame,
and your callback is called.
So, the status of this is it's
coming soon to trusted testers.
Probably early next week.
On the wave, I'll add link for
you to sign up, if you are
interesed in being a trusted
testor for this, and we're
shipping very soon.
And, with that, I'll
hand it off to Brett.
BRETT BAVAR: Thank you, Moishe.
All right, I'm very
excited about that API.
Thank you, Moishe.
Hopefully, you see the
usefulness of this.
Particularly if you're working
an App engine and you want to
control both ends of a
real-time stream of
data in your app.
But there's also a lot
of data out there.
Real time streams that exist
that you don't control.
And what can you do to can
harness the power of that
in your own web apps?
Well I'd like to give
you one solution.
And that is version 2 of the
Feed API with Push Updates.
To give you a little agenda of
what I'm going to talk about,
first I'm going to introduce
the difference between Feed API
Version 1 which you may be
familiar with, and Feed API
Version 2 focusing on the
difference between simply
loading the contents of the
feed and subscribing
to update on a feed.
Then, I'm going to get into a
little more detail of how
exactly you load the contents
of a feed in Feed API v1, so
that we can then see how simple
it is to migrate from the
subscribing to the contents
of the feed on version 2.
Then, we'll talk a little bit
about implementation details.
What's happening
under the hood?
How are updates actually
getting to the browser?
Which is quite similar to
some things that Moishe
just showed you.
And, finally, I'll show you a
few the advanced uses of the
feed API and some of the
function calls and things that
are available to you if you
want to do more than
simply subscribing.
So, the differences in Feed API
Version 1 and Version 2 as I
briefly mentioned before is
the difference between the
loading and subscribing.
In the first case, in Feed API
Version 1 the Feed API makes it
very easy for you to load the
contents of the feed in a
format that's easy to consume
in the browser which I'll talk
about a little bit more later.
It sends it to the browser in
JSON so that it will be used
in Javascript natively.
However, it only loads what the
current contents of the feed
are, and in order to continue
to get updates on that feed,
you have to do polling like
Moishe was talking
about earlier.
In Feed API2 instead,
you subscribe to the
updates on the feeds.
And for any feed that is
pubsubhubbub enabled, you'll be
given the updates of that feed
within seconds of them
being published.
So, lets talk a little bit
about what loading in Feed API
version 1 looks like, so that
we have a little
bit of context.
Here's a simple example
of code using version
1 of the Feed API.
I'll walk you through what
exactly it is doing to load
contents onto the page.
The first thing that happens
is we simply load the API.
This is the Google common
Javascript loader.
We load the module called Feeds
and we load version 1 of it.
We then set an on-load callback
because the API's going to be
loaded asynchronously via JSON.
And we can't be sure that we
can use the API if we simply
run some code using the API
immediately after that.
So, instead, we define a call
back, which I'll show you in a
second, which is going to use
the Feed API code when we know
that it's available because
the load is completed.
So, in that call back function,
we use the feed API,
and it's very simple.
We create an object of
type Google.feeds.feed.
We pass it, in this case, the
URL of the official Google
blog, which we want
to use on our page.
And then we call feed.load with
another call back function.
In this case, to do something
with feed contents.
This call back function is
going to be called one time
after the fetch of the feed
contents is complete.
So, the feed contents are
fetched asnycronously and
passed into this call back
which is defined below.
So that result object is
going to contain the
contents of the feed.
But before I implement this for
you, I want to talk a little
bit about what this result
format looks like.
So you may be familiar with
what feeds look like typically.
They're normally done
in XML, either RSS or
Atom forms of that.
This is a simple RSS Feed.
You can see that the title and
link and description of the
feed are represented here
under the channel tag.
Then there are multiple
items which represent
the entries in the feed.
Each of them also have their
own title link and description.
This is basically what
an RSS feed looks like.
Now, the unfortunate thing
about this, if you working
on a web app, this
XML is heavyweight.
It's complicated to parse.
You really don't want to deal
with this in your web app.
So, what we do in the Feed API,
is we map this in almost a
one-to-one mapping to a JSON
representation, which is
easy to use in Javascript.
As you can see, if I flip back
and forth between these, the
mapping is pretty
straight forward between
the two formats.
Now, JSON, on the the other
hand, if you're familiar with
it, makes it very easy for you
to just use the object as a
native object on Javascript, so
we can look for member feed,
member title, underneath that
and get the title of
the feed and so on.
So given that, I can implement
the call back function here.
You can see I have a very
simple four loop here that
simply iterates through the
entries and it's alerts a
dialog box, telling me what the
title of the each entry is.
Very simple, not very useful,
but you can do some pretty
powerful stuff with
this [? Jason ?]
result format in this
callback function.
So let's look at a demo that
its built with this API.
Here's a page which is
aggregating a couple of
my feeds; a word press
blog and my buzz feed.
You can see that I'm collating
the two together in the
order they were posted.
It's got a bunch of things that
I've posted on to these feeds.
So what does the code
for this look like?
The code starts here.
As you can see, I'm doing some
of the same things that I
did in the sample earlier.
I'm loading Feeds Version
1, setting an on-load call
back, this time called
"in it".
It.
In the in it function
then, I'm declaring two
different objects of type
Google.Google.feeds.feed.
One of which is my buzz feed,
another which is the word
press feed, here with
this wordpress URL.
I'm also using a function I
didn't introduce here which is
simply setting the number of
entries I'm interested in
loading on each feed.
And I'm just setting that right
now to max entries which is the
max entries I want to
display on the page.
So I want to display
12 items on the page.
I'm going to load 12 from each
feed and then collate them and
get rid of the extra ones.
Then I called dot load
on each of these with
a separate call back.
One defined from buzz
updates, one defined
from word press updates.
In each case, I simply add
an entry to the page with
a difference CSS class.
In this case buzz update is the
CSS class and the other word a
press update is the CSS
class, and that allows me to
add the custom styling.
As you can see here; the word
press logo for word press
updates, the buzz logo
for buzz updates.
Then I have some code here that
we don't need to go into detail
of that's simply is creating
the divs to put onto the page.
Collating them by published
date and getting rid of some of
the extra ones at the end since
we're loading twice as many
as we actually want to
display in the beginning.
And that's really
all there is to it.
There's also some CSS
and so on that's doing
styling on the page.
So, that's cool.
What if I wanted to get the
updates from the feeds in real
time so that my users could see
them come in without having to
refresh their page
within seconds?
Well as Moishe talked about,
one thing that we could try,
the old state of the
art, is polling.
But there's not only the
reasons that Moishe talked
about that all apply this case
as well, there's also a couple
of things that we need to
consider specifically
in this case.
For one, we have multiple
levels of cache which prevent
updates from showing
up very quickly.
The Feed API gets lots and lots
of traffic which was mentioned
earlier in a talk this week.
We have to have some
caching to handle that.
There could be anywhere up to
a few minutes of lag caused
by the caches holding onto
updates of the popular feeds.
In addition to that, if you
pull too much, your traffic may
look abusive because you're
hitting that same thing over
and over and over again,
and you may get either
throttled or blocked.
Also if you pull to little,
you might as well just not,
because you're not getting
things quickly anyway.
So, here's the example
I showed you earlier.
I'm proud to introduce very
simple changes that you can
make to this to use the Feed
API version 2, and subscribed
updates in the browser
without polling.
Here's all that I
have to change.
You see here between Feed
API Version 1 and Feed API
Version 2, in order to
subscribe to my feeds.
As you can see, there's
only three simple changes.
First I load Version 2 of the
Feed API, then I create an
object of type feed under the
push named space which is the
type of feed that actually
supports the push up
dates we're going to do.
The reason we have a separate
named space for this is simply
so that we can also support the
old loading cases and Version
2, just in case you still want
to do those kinds of things.
And then I use the dot
subscribe function which is on
the push type feeds, which
takes the same kind
of call back.
But now the call back is going
to be called any time there's
new updates on the feeds
instead of just once.
You can see here, I'll point
out that this call back
actually hasn't changed at all.
Currently the result format
of these is exactly the
same as Feed API Version 1.
This will probably change with
time, but I believe that we
would like to keep at least the
resolve format, consistent
between loading and subscribing
in Version 2, and so that it's
very easy to work between two.
So, if you actually wanted to
take some code that you've had
that does this already in Feed
API Version 1, your call back
doesn't need to change at all.
Although in practical
applications you're probably
going to want to do something
different, because it's no
longer going to just be called
once, its going to be
called multiple time.
You want some items to expire
and not continue to add things
to page, and just make
it growing indefinitely
and kill your browser.
You also may want to add some
cool animation or something
and things pop in.
Let's look at this same demo
that I showed you before, but
slightly modified in ways that
showed you in order to
enable push up dates.
I am going to bring up the
dashboard of my word press
blog and I'm going
to add a new post.
All right, let me resize
this, so we can see a little
better what's going on.
I'm going publish
this to word press.
You can see word press is
working on that a little
bit, and there it is.
Popped into my page without
doing any sort of refresh
in just a matter of
a couple seconds.
I'll explain to you in a
second what actually went
on behind the scenes.
I can do the same
thing with buzz.
And we should see this pop
also in just a few seconds.
There it is.
So, what's different?
This looks very much like the
demo code I showed you before.
All that's different here, as
I said before, we changed
this to Version 2.
We have the same
on-load call back.
Now we're using dot
push, dot feed.
We're also using dot subscribe
in the same way I explained.
I'll also introduce this
a little bit later.
This includes historical
entries function.
This allows me to load some
historical content, so the
page doesn't start being
blank at the beginning.
Everything else after that
is actually identical code.
In both cases, I was loading
more than I needed at the the
beginning and discarded
extra entries.
In this case, as entries
continue to come in all, I'll
continue to throw out the
entries that are off
the end of the list.
OK, so how does this work?
In order to explain that, I
need to first introduce you to
something called pubsubhubbub.
You may seen Brett Slakins talk
on this earlier this week.
If not, I recommend it.
It was very good.
And it will be on YouTube
hopefully very soon.
You can also the
code.google.com/p/pubsubhubbub
to get some details on this.
Pubsubhubbub was a protocol
that was invented by couple of
engineers including Brett
Slatkin, himself at Google, and
some other people they
cooperated with, for the
sake of turning feeds into
streaming content streams.
And the way this happens
is using a pubsub model
with a hub in between.
So, I'm going to brush
over this very quickly.
You should get the details
elsewhere, because this is a
little bit beyond the scope of
my talk, but I just want to
introduce it very briefly.
So the whole protocol
uses HTTP posts.
The subscribers are going to
post their interest on a
particular feed to the hub.
They know which hub the feed
uses by reading it out of the
feed, which I'll show
you very shortly.
They tell the hub, I'm
interested in this.
Please post all updates to
x-URL, then whenever the
publisher publishes update on
that feed, it tells the hub
there's new content
on this feed.
The hub fetches that new
content and pushes it through
an HTP post to all of
the URLs that have been
registered to that feed.
So there's a lot of content
out there that's all ready
pubsubhubbub enabled and you
may wonder how you can know
which of those do this already.
One thing very simply is this
the same feed I showed you
before, and if you were to open
up this feed, and you saw
something like this; link
rel="hub", with some
URL of a hub, you could know
that this feed should be
pubsubhubbub enabled.
And you should be able to go
to that and subscribe on it.
Using the Feed API, however,
you don't need to worry
about those details.
You can just know that
this will work with
Feed API Version 2.
Some things that actually come
out of the box right now with
pubsubhubbub; support on, blogs
on blogger dot com, on word
press doc com, on type pad,
your own hosted word press
blogs if you use the push press
plug in, tumbler,
[? posterous ?]
all sorts of things that
I've probably left out.
Google buzz, of course,
as I showed you earlier.
All these things come
with pubsubhubbub just
built-in to the box.
So you should have no trouble
if you want to publish yourself
to one of these kinds of the
feeds with pubsubhubbub
enabled, or if you just want to
consume the content
from someone else.
All right, so pubsubhubbub
works pushing between servers
because it uses HTPP posts.
But how exactly do we get
from there to pushing
to the browser?
Well, the first thing that
happens when feed.subscribe is
called is that a request is
made to Google's servers saying
please bind a comet
channel for me.
This is the same technology,
basically, that Moishe was
talking about earlier.
It's going to bind a comet
channel and I'll show you a
little bit about that
a little bit later.
So the comet channel is
established and then another
message is sent to Google's
server saying, I'm interested
in this particular feed URL.
So, it's going to send Google
Blog to blogspot.com and so on,
send that to Google server,
saying please give me updates
on this feed, I want
to subscribe to it.
So Google is going to check
and say, OK, am I already
subscribed to the
updates on this feed?
If it is, it doesn't need to do
anything, but in a lot of cases
it may not yet be subscribed to
that, so it's going to do the
pubsubhubbub subscriptions
step with the hub that was
declared for that feed.
So, Google's going to send a
URL to the hub saying whenever
there's updates on this feed,
send them to this URL that
Google controls and that we
can receive updates on.
Then, at some point, the feed
publisher publishes via
pubsubhubbub, let'ls the hub
know there's new content, the
hub fetches that content from
feed publisher, and it turns
around and posts that to all
of the subscribers including
the URLS that were
registered by Google.
Then, Google can check and
see if anyone currently
interested in this update?
Is there anyone subscribed in
Feed API Version 2, and if so,
it will push along those
channels that were established
for all the users that are
subscribed in that feed.
That is really all
there is to it.
Let me go back to the demo
I showed you a second ago,
and give you a feel for
what this looks like.
We look in Chrome developer
tools and see alot of
the resources that
were loaded here.
You can see that we started the
channel around here, so you'll
notice first we do a couple
tests to see what kind of comet
channel is supported
on this browser.
We do an initial bind to get a
channel ID, and then we get
this hanging get request.
You can see it lasted for about
a minute before it timed out
and then another one was
created and continued to
keep this connection open.
In some of the cases, when
contact was sent along probably
much later on here when I did
the pushes -- well I'm not
finding it-- in one of these,
we would see the content that
was actually pushed along.
The connection is held out as
long as it possibly can and
whenever it closes the client's
going to re-open that
connection hold it out longer,
and oh -- here we go-- here's
exactly where I push to
both of those feeds.
You can see it went over this
connection during that one
minute that one was open.
And you can just see the
content of the feed updates
that were sent along there.
So the client is holding this
connection open as the content
comes along, it is grabbing it
and throwing it into the call
back that was registered
by the developer.
So, that's how
things are pushed.
Now let's talk a little
bit about some advanced
uses of the API.
So first of all, as you saw in
the demo, I had the include
historical entries function.
This simply gives us the
loading functionality of old
API Version 1 without having
to define two separate feed
objects and two separate call
backs to handle those cases.
What I can say is I don't want
my page to be blank when I
first start, so I want to load
20 historical entries first.
But I want them all to be
passed to the same call back
that I want the real time
updates to be sent to later.
That just makes it a
little bit simpler.
You could very easily also do
this with Feed API Version 1,
if you wanted to do something
different in the case of the
initial load and in the case of
the streaming updates later,
but this just makes it a little
simpler, if the call back
is the same in both cases.
Another thing you can do, is
you can subscribe to multiple
feeds, as I showed
you in the demo.
You simply create two
feeds of type push feeds.
And in this case, one is
official Google blog and one
is the Google Code Blog.
One thing to note, in this
case, we're only going to
keep one channel open.
As you saw, there was a single
connection at any given time.
We're going to multi-plex the
updates on that channel again.
As you saw both, both of
the updates for both feeds
were on the same channel.
A little more advanced; if
you're interested in knowing
when the channel is bound
and when it's unbound.
This does not include the cases
where the channel is simply
disconnected and reconnected
immediately, naturally, but in
the case that say there's
network loss and its down for
longer than anticipated.
Maybe you picked up your laptop
and walked between WIFI hot
spots, maybe the laptop was
closed for a while, then you
popped it open again, and it's
trying to reconnect again.
We have a couple of call backs
that you can use to identify
when the channel has been
connected and disconnected.
So, first, there's the on-bind
call back which will let you
know when you've been bound,
and there is the on-unbound
call back which will let you
know when you've been unbound.
And, you'll notice these are
on the Google.feeds.push
name space statically.
They're not on any particular
feed object, because again, we
share one single channel
between multiple feeds.
So, these events would only
happen once if the channel
disconnected for all feeds
that you've subscribe to.
And then you just give
it a call back and that
call back will happen.
In this case, it would just
alert a dialog box saying
what event changes happened.
And, finally, you may have a
case where you want to
subscribe your users to feed
for a while, and then they're
not interested in that, maybe
they are interested in
something else, so you want to
unsubscribe and not get updates
for that any more, and you want
to subscribe to something else.
We have a simple unsubscribe
function to stop
receiving updates on that
particular feed.
Eventually, also we currently
don't have this implemented,
but probably if you're not
subscribed to anything, your
unsubscribed from all the feeds
that you were subscribed to,
we'll probably just eventually
cut off that channel because
it's not needed anymore.
All right, so that's really
all there is to it.
If you want to get started,
we're opening it up right now
just for white listed testers.
You can go to
code.google.com/apis/feed/push
to see the documentation and
also to sign up on a form if
you're interested in using it.
Eventually, we hope to open
this up to everybody but we're
just taking steps to release
it out slowly and
see how it works.
You can also play around
with it a little bit at
code.google.com/playground.
Look under the Feeds
section and the push
subsection of that.
There's a couple of different
simple examples of
that [INAUDIBLE]
[?___[SECTION___
MISSING___DUE___
TO___TECHNICAL___DIFFICULTIES]
?]
AUDIENCE: Does
this mean that App Engine
is going to support
real time comet push?
MOISHE LETTVIN:
BRETT BAVAR: Yes.
BRETT BAVAR: OK any
other questions?
We've got one here.
AUDIENCE: I was wonder how
does your Javascript library
compared to the Strophe?
MOISHE LETTVIN: That's
a very good question.
So, Strophe is the
Javascript XMPP library.
Is that correct?
So, we're not pushing full
XMPP down to the client.
We're basically collapsing a
bunch of it on the server side
and sending just a very
compressed JSON format down so
it's much less chatty
then Strophe.
AUDIENCE: Is there any hope
for near term support for
GWT widgets support on the
client for the channel?
GWT support on the client
side for the channel.
MOISHE LETTVIN: Oh, yes, we're
working on that, absolutely.
Good question.
BRETT BAVAR: Anything else?
OK.
I think we're done.
[APPLAUSE]